good morning everyone and apologies for
the
for a little delay welcome to this press
conference
following the publication of the new
risk assessment by the european center
on disease prevention
and control today we have with us
commissioner aquires and the director of
the ecdc
mrs amman i will first give the floor to
the commissioner and to the director to
make some introductory comments
and then as usual i'll open the floor
for all questions
that you may have commissioner the floor
is here thank you
thank you and good morning everyone
kovite 19 is the public health crisis
of course we have all feared it has
turned upside down the way we lead our
live our lives how we interact with each
other
how we are when we are in social spaces
the way we work
i would say that no part of our lives
has remained unaffected
the disruptive but necessary
restrictions placed by most member
states during the spring
did manage to slow down the spread of
the virus
and allowed us to slowly but gradually
start to get back to what we have often
said
will be our new normal however
the much expected and i would say needed
lifting of some of the restrictions
during the early summer
has led to what we have continuously
cautioned against
an increase in cases as you will hear
from
our director andrea ammon in some member
states
the situation is now even worse
than during the peak in march
this is a real cause for concern
what this means to be very clear is that
the control measures
taken have simply not been effective
enough
or not being enforced or
followed as they should have been this
is clearly
underlined in the updated risk
assessment to be presented today
by ecdc
while people testing positive for
covid19
are younger in several member states and
mortality rates remain
lower than before we are starting to see
an increase in the occupancy of icu
we cannot lower our guard this crisis
is not behind us moreover
autumn and winter are the time of the
year for more respiratory illnesses
including seasonal influenza
to prevent what could potentially be a
lethal
twindemic of covid19 and the flu
which could overburden our health
systems and lead to more loss of life
we need to increase the coverage of
vaccination rates
today against what frankly is a very
worrying background
i see an absolute necessity to send a
strong and clear message to member
states
that our recommendations on short-term
preparedness that we
issued in july are more valid than ever
from stepped up testing to closer
contact tracing
from improved public health surveillance
to better access to personal protective
equipment and medicines
and ensuring sufficient healthcare
capacity in icu units
all member states need to roll out
measures
immediately and at the right time
at the very first sign of potential new
outbreaks
of course i will say it is encouraging
to see that progress has been made
notably on the agreement of a common eu
approach to testing
and i urge all member states to follow
this
we are we still see
and we still we are hearing now the how
from several member states how they are
moving across with implementing the
urgent actions we presented in july
but hearing that today we are okay
is not enough are we planning for the
worst case scenarios
we have put in place tools for in the eu
to support this effort as was
required and asked of us
joint procurements for supplies for
intensive care units and treatments
are there to be used and plan ahead
we have delivered the first batches of
the only authorized covid19 treatment
room deficient
purchased under the eu emergency support
instrument and
are already negotiations for the next
joint procurement for this
we are negotiating with pharmaceutical
companies for kovit 19 vaccines
as many of you know have concluded two
contracts so far
to ensure access to such vaccines once
proven
safe and effective finally
we are working with member states and we
will insist
on a coordinated approach on free
movement restrictions
to ensure more clarity and
predictability for citizens
we have already presented this proposal
but we have not yet
achieved member state consensus on this
and i urge
member states to move ahead it is
extremely important
but with the covet 19 vaccine being
months away
i'm deeply concerned by what we are
seeing now
and what may follow in the coming coming
weeks and
months we we all need to understand that
finding a vaccine will not be a silver
bullet
citizens we all are the first line of
defense against covet 19
and our self-discipline to adhere to
measures will determine the next month
we must prevent a situation where
governments
feel they have no choice but to improve
in post-generalized lockdowns
this will be detrimental detrimental to
our mental health
detrimental to our economies detrimental
to the well-being and education of our
children
detrimental to our working and daily
lives
we have to take measures that will
protect those around us whether they are
parents or grandparents or those
vulnerable
in our societies to support member
states we have also today
with ecdc issued guidance on
non-pharmaceutical interventions
andrew will be speaking about this
immediately after myself
these are the most effective public
health interventions
against covid19 that we have today
we are in some places and i understand
witnessing a real covid19
fatigue with physical distancing and an
apparent disregard of the norms
and even we're seeing protests in some
member states
this needs to be addressed by member
states and we need to find ways to deal
with it
i urge member states to reach out to
young people
to make them understand the situation
that we are all up against
we need to do everything possible to
find to fight
misinformation and for fake news which
is creating even more confusion in
citizens
and andrew will be able to speak a
little bit about what we're seeing now
in the new cases of covert 19
relation to the age demographics
here i would call on member states to be
consistent
and coherent in their communication and
ensure as much as predictability as
possible
to allow citizens and businesses to
remain
and have a sense of control i am
convinced that predictability and clear
communication to citizens
and coordination with other member
states will
increase compliance and protective
measures
i have already stressed and i cannot
stress strongly enough
that we are responsible for each other
we must
all regardless of age regardless of
vulnerability continue to keep physical
distancing
wear face masks take care of hand
hygiene
try to meet the person only within our
social bubble of relatives
and stay home when we feel sick
ladies and gentlemen we are at a
decisive moment
today we're here to call on everyone to
act decisive
decisively too it might be
our last chance to prevent a repeat
of last spring i will now immediately
pass the floor over to stefan
and then to andrea who and andrew will
present the details of the later
ecdc assessment published today as well
as the guidance on non-pharmaceutical
measures
thank you thank you commissioner and
i'll give the floor to uh
director aman director please go ahead
yeah thank you very much and good
morning to
everybody i'm happy to present
uh the key messages from the two
documents that we have published today
as mentioned by the commissioner we are
seeing
an increase of cases in the
across the eu countries and apart from
the increased testing that contributes
to the increase
we are seeing in several countries
progress from local transmission
to more sustained community transmission
as mentioned the
large number of the cases right now
are among younger people which comprises
the age group between 50
and 49 15 and 49
and although these uh this uh this age
group
has a lower probability for severe cases
severe cases occur in this age group
so among the cases reported to us in the
past four weeks
44 of the severe cases were among this
age group
and what the other concern is uh from
our side
is that uh this increasing transmission
in this age group
may also uh go over to
the more vulnerable older age groups in
our in our
population in our risk assessment we
have
um grouped uh or the risk
that we assessed for this risk
assessment we have grouped
countries in three groups
so there is one group of countries with
stable trends
that include a lower proportion of
elderly cases among elderly
lower proportion among of severe cases
and a low proportion
of death notifications and for this
group
the risk is considered low
for this group of countries or areas in
countries because
i haven't mentioned that that
although we are talking about an
increase it's very different situation
for the different countries and even in
some countries within the country
so the third the second group that we
are looking at
is cases with
countries with concerning trends and
here um these countries are
characterized
by high and increasing notification
rates
reported due to increased testing
and the transmission is still primarily
among
younger age groups with a low proportion
of severe cases and
low death notification rates and here
the risk is moderate
the last group is countries with trends
of high concern
and these are countries that have
where we see increasing notification in
all the cases
increased proportion of hospitalized and
severe cases
probably due to this higher notification
in older cases
and we're also so seeing in these
countries increasing or already high
notice death notification cases and here
the risk is high
and for the vulnerable individuals in
all these countries
the risk is very high anyway
so what can be done
in principle we have to control
the transmission among older children
and adults younger than 50 years of age
and i can go in more details
afterwards we have to ensure that
those that are social socially and
medically vulnerable
are protected and we have to protect our
healthcare workers
so these are the three things the three
objectives that need now to
to be be implemented
as the commissioner has mentioned we
have published
together with the risk assessment also a
document
on non-pharmaceutical interventions
and the reason is as already also
mentioned by the commissioner
that in the absence of a vaccine this is
the basically the only tool that we have
in this document uh there is nothing new
so we haven't come up with any any new
measures
however we have uh put together
all the evidence and the knowledge that
has been gained over the past month
where these measures for the first time
actually
has have been applied in a in a large
context
we have put this together and the idea
is
that countries due to the different
epidemiological situation in the
countries
can now go and have a look what will
work
best in their specific context
now while these measures may have a
certain variation
depending on the epidemiological
analysis in a country
there are certain measures that have to
be
in place everywhere all the time
and that is sufficient testing capacity
rigorous contact tracing and
a good quality for contacts
and a good risk communication and this
risk communication has to be tailored
to different parts of the population in
different ways
so we have on the one hand the general
population
that needs to be made aware
why these measures still have to be in
place
for physical distancing wearing a face
mask if this cannot uh
the distance cannot be kept and staying
at home
when having symptoms and proper hand
hygiene
and that their contribution is really
essential
in order to control the pandemic but
then there has to be a
communication addressed to the
vulnerable population
because they also have to give their
means
how to protect themselves and the last
group that needs to be addressed
separately are the younger ones
because some behavioral studies that
have been
carried out uh make it very clear they
feel themselves
in invulnerable and have no concerns
that they could uh
actually transmit any any um uh
disease or the virus so the
the these risk communication efforts
have to be really stepped up
to ensure the compliance
to the measures that countries have to
put up
i close it here because
i would like to leave enough room and
time
for your questions thank you thank you
very much director
we are now indeed going to open the
floor for your questions i see that
several of you have raised their hands
the first question goes to david david
carreta
please go ahead
thank you thank you very much david
italian radio commissioner we are seeing
counter is going in different directions
belgium is
[Music]
leaving some social distancing measures
even if the number of
people tested positive is increasing
on the other side of the border france
is
imposing new restrictions
what is the model that you are promoting
and is it
feasible to have counters going in
different direction with different
strategies in front of this
second wave thank you
yes i'll pick this up and then also ask
andrew to comment on this i'll just say
that we have been very clear
on the model that we have been uh asking
member states to follow from our
preparations communication on the 15th
of july
we were very clear that what needs to be
done in terms of
member states is the level of
preparedness to include
uh as andre has said testing contact
tracing social distancing
it is also understandable that different
countries
are at different stages of the
epidemiological curve
and of course within countries you see
differences
so we would expect this but what we do
what we do expect
is that member states have in place what
they need
to to do in order to be prepared so when
they have cases they're immediately
be able to take uh um measures
um and if andrew would like to comment
on this director
maybe you would like to add something
yes thank you as i said
at this stage with such a diverse
picture across europe
it's not possible to say everybody has
to do the same
but everybody has to monitor what's
happening
uh and this is why we're we're we're um
also saying that robust surveillance
that allows for timely recognition
of any changes speed in one age group or
overall be it in one part of the country
or overall
has to has to be um uh in place to
support
uh the tailoring of the mess uh the
measure measures
but at this stage there is no way that
with these different situations in the
countries we can say
everybody has to do the same except for
those
measures that i have highlighted that
should be in place everywhere
thank you thank you director um the next
question goes to angelo di mambro angelo
the floor is yours
hello can you hear me we hear you loud
and clear
thanks um the european the
the german presidency it's uh not so
long ago has published a a
a document in which the it's clear that
the discussion on
on on things like a joint risk
assessment and possible common measures
uh i quote the document seem
particularly sensitive
um the discussion among member states uh
what is
what is your comment that are we so far
from
from having a a common approach to
the interpretation of the data and then
on the actions to be undertaken thanks
i believe we've come a long way in terms
of the coordination what we need
from member states and we have put
forward
a number of recommendations including a
recent one on testing
strategies and member states and through
the health security committee have
adopted these
so um as andrea said what we are seeing
is different situations involving
different member states
what i would like to send as a message
today
is that all member states need to have
certain things in place
uh and then from then on uh the the
measures that they take at times
um will depend on their uh on their
local situations
so um i think that we have a
better level of coordination definitely
through to the recommendations uh but i
would say that there are
areas where we need to highlight uh and
improve
our overall framework
thank you i'm sorry if i may also add uh
for this reason we're also having the
lessons learned package coming out in
november
thank you commissioner um and then i see
sophie la pauletto
you need to push the legendary speak
button
yes can you hear me sorry i will ask my
question in in french if i may the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
thank you yeah the duration of
quarantine
is under debate right now in particular
because it is uh
um by some countries combined with
the uh with tests and
we are currently looking into um
what the impact would be um in
in coming to a general
general uh uh recommendation
what did what uh what we would say
currently
uh as we haven't concluded is uh
this uh considerations and deliberations
we still have uh uh adherence to the 14
days
thank you very much um for the second
and third question i will pass for the
commissioner commissioner the
question number two was is this the last
chance we're talking about and second
what about the obligatory participation
in vaccine contracts concluded
with vaccine developers i think the
first question
well the second question but the first
to me uh
was exactly the reason that we are
standing here today yes we are concerned
and that is why we're here with uh
with andrea to to share this concern and
to really
highlight the importance that we need
to ensure that these messages
of where we are with the with the covet
19
are really get through to everyone
and i want to say something you said why
now but my
question for me is is i think you you
can answer it
is we're seeing an increase in the
number of new cases in so many member
states
so this is a time when we need to
make sure and ensure that we have
the mobilized all the resources that we
have raised since the july
communication to make sure that we are
able to cope
with this number and
i would repeat that yes i have no
no reason to hide the fact that we are
concerned and i am concerned that the
situation as it stands now
the second question i think had to do
with the vaccines if i understood
um yes we said we have concluded and
signed two agreements
the one with astrazeneca and the other
one with sanofi jsk
these these are agreements and contracts
that have been signed following
uh negotiations in which the commission
is in the process with all 27 member
states so all 27 member states are part
of this
negotiation process and
are part of the um of the
agreements once they are signed thank
you
thank you commissioner we had a question
from thomas miglerina thomas
trying to click this
okay yes um i have a specific question
on the cooperation with
switzerland and i would like both the
technician and the politicians
assessment
switzerland it's in the middle of europe
it's important the situation
is not good at the same time we know
that we miss an agreement
of cooperation so for example there will
be no interoperability of the
app there is an emergency participation
to the ecdc exchange for information
that was granted
given the the situation so i would like
your assessment
and how uh complicated it is for the
european
um union for the european side to have
this
whole this grey hole in all the ecdc
maps thank you
i'll take the first part and let andre
answer the second
i'd just like to to to let you know that
we have extended
um our cooperation with switzerland uh
in the health security committee
and um correctly in our information
uh exchange system so uh we fully agree
that uh we need to cooperate we're in a
pandemic viruses no no borders
and we're doing everything possible to
be as inclusive and
of course exchange information
as effectively as possible with all
thank you
director you would like to add something
yes
yes thank you i just want to say that uh
the corpora
the level of cooperation that ecdc can
have with countries
depends on the um uh uh
eu level decision what kind of
cooperation between the eu
and this country uh uh is happening and
that is uh
um uh uh an independent of the fact
that uh for for this cooperation for
this
for this pandemic we have to work uh
work together globally
but for specific things like you
mentioned the map this
depends on the uh cooperation level that
is agreed
between the eu and the country and we
have to abide by that
thank you the next question is for odile
odile
we bonjour merci or francaise
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
a
shall i pick it up okay in while we're
waiting for the
um i'll i'll pick this up i yes i
understand the
concerns and i'd remind um ourselves
that in in the summer we came out with a
tourism and travel package because we we
understood that we needed to have as
much coordination as possible
and we're doing everything possible to
coordinate
and be able to allow free movement to
continue as
as fluently as possible as fluidly as
possible in a pandemic
we have put a proposal on the table
a proposal on coordinated approach to
free movement restrictions
i believe and we believe that this will
create
more clarity and predictability for
citizens and for businesses
member states are discussing it but as i
have said in my opening
remark remarks they need to deliver
results faster and i urge them to
deliver results faster
and andrew me thank you um
miss aman if you have something to add
from the ecdc perspective
please yeah only that
i mean we have been working together
with our colleagues
sister agencies that work in the
transport sector with the
evasion safety agency the railway agency
and also the maritime safety agency
to come up with protocols for the case
that
travel on these
respective transportation devices is
is done that is how far we can go
and we are working with the council in
helping
to reach an um
consensus on on common
travel measures thank you
jillian dodge the floor is yours now
jillian go ahead
go ahead hi thanks so much uh
commissioner kirakidis and dr emman for
being here today
um i have a few questions if you'll
allow me um first um
obviously back to these um harmonized
border measures and quarantine rules
governments have been talking for quite
some time and still have not come to an
agreement
i was wondering what's taking so long
and even if governments
do agree to some harmonized roles if
commissioner carry case you agree if you
believe that they will actually be
implemented in the end
um my next question is for dr amman um
we're seeing high transmission in
younger people
i was wondering then what governments
should do now to ensure we don't go back
to full lockdown so we're talking
you know governments should shut bars
down should they shut schools down we
need these circuit breakers
curious if you can give us kind of a
nutshell what governments can do and
last very quickly um
i was also curious about um you know
we're nervous that covet will coincide
with the flu
um i'm curious that if we have any
updates on harmonized vaccine plans
between you countries
vaccination plans excuse me yes you are
you referring to the
vaccination plans for the seasonal flu
right
yes i'll take that as a yes um maybe
maybe
yes thank you i'll take this yes
thank you thank you jillian for those
questions um
first of all what what is taking member
states so long
for the harmonized rules we put forward
the harmonized rules for travel because
we believe that this is necessary
and this is why i urge today
to move more quickly on this so
i don't have anything uh else to add to
that
will they be implemented well i think
that
it is extremely important that we
implement everything that we agree on
across the board when you're dealing
with a pandemic
so i would hope that once they are
agreed on and i urge again that these
are agreed on as soon as possible
then they will be implemented
effectively um
on the third the question i think one
question was to andre but if i may take
up my question which was on the the flu
vaccine
this has been a concern for us from the
summer months and we came out with this
in our july
uh communication as well um so
we we this twindemic of possibility of
the combination of
of of the flu with covet 19.
the health security committee has
already discussed and agreed on
on a common strategy of course
vaccination policies you know are a
national
um prerogatives
but i believe that by discussing it as
we have in the health security committee
and putting forward our recommendations
we are able to encourage them to all
work in the same direction
thank you and then we still had a
question on
younger people i think that questions
for director aman
yes thank you the
what what can be done now is
really target certain measures towards
this younger age group and since
their the increased transmission
happened somewhere what countries should
do now
is identify those settings that uh where
in particular younger people meet and
that might be different settings in
different countries
the next step would be to consider
whether
these settings have to be
closed or whether it's possible to
restrict access
like a certain percentage or
number of people so that proper physical
distancing can be
can be um adhered to but then
also uh that has to be accompanied
by really a proper risk communication to
to to younger people because as i said
before
they are aware that the virus exists but
they don't feel that it
that that it's a concern for them and i
think that has to be
um
[Music]
conveyed that a also younger people can
have severe
disease and they can also transmit it to
people that have a higher likelihood of
actually having a severe cause of course
the um uh
i just wanted to say regarding the uh
influenza
uh we have always said that the the
uh influenza vaccination for the targets
groups
should be intensified this year so that
the the the level of coverage among
elderly people and also healthcare
workers
and people with underlying disease
is higher than in the past years we are
working with
who and the member states on protocols
how to do um surveillance for
influenza and covet in the winter in
parallel
to be able to keep track of both of the
diseases
thank you for young for young people i
think it's important that we understand
that we're not here
to blame young people but young people
often
receive communication messages in
different ways and
what we are saying is that what we are
and ecdc and andrea has stressed
is we have seen a change in the numbers
in the ages
so uh member states need to address this
specifically
with communication strategies which are
going to be young people friendly
so the messages really get across it's
important
that we really see this and this is why
we give these risk assessments
because breaking them down then it
allows member states to see
where they should be addressing their
communication but also their strategies
thank you thank you very much and we
have our next question coming from
moses um
i see i'm sorry a little confusion here
no i see verena
verena please you have the floor
i hope you can hear me now
hello we hear you
super i'm very national goshman with the
german press agency dpa
um i was wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit more on the
measures
to be taken now because on the one hand
you say the measures
taken have not been effective
even though testing and tracing has been
stepped up in many
member states and masks are much more
common
and people are getting used to wearing
them
so my question is are those
the measures at our disposal effective
at all could you mention some that could
be
more effective and a final consequence
could a second lockdown be avoided at
all
thank you thank you very much verena i
will pass the floor to dr aman
go ahead doctor yeah thank you
coming to your last point i think all
what we're doing right now
and why we're raising now the the alarm
is
to avoid exactly that we have to go into
a situation of intensity of measures
as we had in spring in our
in our document on the
non-pharmaceutical interventions
we have at the end a table where we have
listed
all the measures and also from our side
the recommendation when they should be
implemented
with an assessment of the
impact the social and economic impact
so the the
[Music]
what we know from the effectiveness is
that when they are implemented as a
package as we did in spring
they have an effect what we are
less sure is what the single measures
what their effectiveness is
and that is something why i uh
highlighted before that when a measure
is implemented it needs to be
really under um a
good scrutiny with surveillance to see
whether it has an effect or not
and um if for instance the effectiveness
is hampered by uh adherence or
compliance
then countries may have to think about
whether enforcement measures
should be taken and some countries
actually are doing this
so there are maybe some some elements
that uh
countries can add compared to what is
doing right now
and also regarding the face masks the
the use in the countries is quite
has quite a variation and the
when we when we compare measures from
june and september
there are also now fewer countries that
have
measures implemented thank you doctor
i will now give the photo mariapsara
sorry maria you're supposed to have the
floor
earlier but please can you hear me now
hello from my part uh one
political question i suppose it is
obvious that nobody wants
a new lockdown it's true but on contrary
in
countries like belgium for example
although the number of the cases
raises we see that the measures are easy
evening
so the question is are the member states
in contact with the commission
and with ecdc i suppose yes so
do you have the impression that the
member states follow your
guidelines listen to you listen to what
you say and your concerns
and if not what can the commission do
for that
thank you very much thank you very much
for the question
dr amon are we following your advice
um i think to a certain degree if you
want to have a short answer
but i have to highlight that the
responsibility
for the measures taken really lies with
the countries
and in some countries it's not even the
national level that has the
responsibility but some regional or even
local level
so um there is uh what we can do
is say what is um uh what are
is the is the is the range of measures
that can be taken
what is the evidence that they can uh
work and
uh what would be a potential impact of
these measures
but in the end the member states are
responsible for the
for taking the measures and also
accountable for the result
can we come in here as well and just add
to what
[Music]
andrea said and i'll come back to i
think it was also jillian made this
point
uh member states we have a coordination
we have a good level of communication
with their
their working with ecdc and through the
health security committee
and measures are being put into place
but measures being put into place
the question that comes immediately is
how are they implemented
and this is something that we need to
that thing we need to address
whether they're put into place are we
then overseeing their implementations
so that they're getting maximum
effectiveness so this is one question
and the second question is in terms of
communication
is um i think that we all need to
understand that we as citizens are the
first line of defense in a pandemic
so implementation of measures is also a
responsibility that we have on an
individual level but
also the enforcement and the
implementation of measures is something
which is the political level
is with member states thank you thank
you and i now
will now pass the floor to mosey mosey
go ahead
thank you very much stefan yes i would
like to ask a brief question to director
amon uh you talked about the let's say
the trends statistics and the risk
assessments
and the increase in notification on your
cases
and that could as we said they also
depend on the increase of
uh of tests my question is
is there a crucial parameter in
in the form of the of the percentage of
the person tested positive
is that something which is a payment
which is
the same for all countries so that this
depends on the
national circumstances some in some
countries it has increased to more than
let's say 10 percent at least in the
first wave
so so my question is
how do you how should we interpret
this parameter and do you see an
increasing trend also in
in in the in this parameter thank you
thank you director aman yes thank you
for the question um indeed
the figure to to look at the
notification figures and the trend alone
is not sufficient because
this depends on not only how many tests
are done but also who is tested
and as said many times there are
different strategies and approaches in
the countries
that we tried to since
early on to to really standardize
uh this this this approach now when we
look at the
numbers of tests carried out per hundred
thousand inhabitants
there's a wide variation in the
countries it ranges from
a few hundred to several thousand tests
per hundred thousand uh inhabitants
and in our risk assessment
you find when you go there to on page
three
really a curve that shows how the tests
in the countries went up and they are
still increasing so countries are still
increasing the capacity and then a
second curve
the same in the same graph
that shows the percentage of these tests
being positive
and we're looking at both of these
parameters together
because if you
increase the tests and you have
increasing numbers
but the percentage of the tests that
are positive remains low that means
that the increase is due to the increase
in testing so the increase on cases
is then due to the increase in testing
whereas what you can see now from august
starting
it's an increase in the percentage of
positive tests
and that is for us the alarming part
well because
now we we we see that the the
the rate of positive tests is uh
increasing which means that there is
increasing
uh transmission so that is the
the connection between the the
case notifications the number of the the
number of tests per hundred thousand and
the percentage that is positive
that has to be looked at it together
thank you
thank you i have to take into account
that the sooner uh midday briefing
starts so i will not be able to take all
questions but
i now give the floor to samwell
somewhere we'll go ahead
[Music]
press
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
is
thank you for that question in terms of
the of the uh
sanofi vaccine uh first of all i will
say that
we know that the safe and effective
vaccine is going to be the surest way of
exit um from the covet 19 pandemic and
this is why
the european commission has the the
vaccine strategy
and we're working with with and for the
member states in order to ensure a broad
portfolio
which will help help us
um and have a safe and effective vaccine
when this is available
for all in terms of predictions i'm not
able to make a prediction
we have seen how in clinical trials
phase three
you can face many uncertainties so
i would not go as far as putting any
predictions in terms of timelines
we're following all very closely
together with
of course the european medicines agency
and we await to see the results
thank you thank you um
dr aman perhaps on the um
and collective immunity yes um uh
regarding uh the uh the measures
um it's very clear that closures of
shops and and venues has an
in a societal impact um uh the basic
measure that has to be taken
is have keep a physical distance
and put on a mask if you can't and a
hand hygiene
now the taking these more
drastic measures of closure of shops and
venues
bars restaurants depends on how well
it's possible to ensure these basic
measures
in these venues so if it's possible to
have
distancing in a restaurant or in a bar
then i think it's a different uh
consideration to t to close or not then
if it's such a small place that uh only
one person can also a few persons can be
in there anyway
so i think there are it's very difficult
to to to give
a generalized advice here
but the basic measure is if you are able
to keep distance
then that's the safest thing now
regarding the herd immunity
this is something that is under constant
observation
from the data that we have uh until
today
um uh the the level of uh
uh uh people uh with
antibodies is still not very high
so in most places it's a maximum
15 percent usually lower and only on
very
small local uh communities that had a
high
exposure uh during spring uh it is
higher
so i think it's still not the uh the the
time
to rely that most of the people actually
cannot be infected on the contrary
most of the people still can be infected
thank you
thank you i'll give the floor now to
nami o'leary
naomi thank you thank you very much for
taking my question
um so given the increased evidence of
the key role of
shared air in transmitting the virus
shouldn't you
include ventilation and the importance
of not being confined spaces in
conversation
um to those distancing and hand hygiene
precepts as well this question is for dr
aman
in addition given the increasing
evidence of enduring things like
neurological
organ and lung damage on younger
survivors of cote covered 19
what picture is now emerging of the
medium to long-term impact
on population health and finally why
does the ecdc advise only
forward-looking contact tracing finding
out who the contact has passed on the
virus to
rather than backward-looking contract
tracing to find out where it's being
transmitted
given that it's different from country
to country in different cultures
and as you said it's really important
that measures are specifically targeted
to where it's being spread in each place
thanks thank you first the commissioner
will come in and then i'll give the
heart to the director
very briefly i want to come in just to
to say a point
because you mentioned the the impact of
those who have been through covert 19
just to share with you that i had
a meeting an online meeting with the
european association for chronic
diseases a week ago
because as health commissioner i'm
speaking with all the
groups of health patient groups uh and
in relation to other issues as well and
of course covet
and it is of concern and it is also one
of my concerns and i will be taking
this up with with of course my
colleagues and health ministers
the fact that we are seeing a number of
uh chronic diseases
um increase because of uh of covert 19.
so
covet 19 really we need to monitor it at
many different levels
and this is something that we have uh
already been alerted to thank you thank
you director emman you would like to
come in as well i think
yes uh regarding the ventilation and the
air quality we have already in summer
published a
document on the influence of
air condition airing airing
indoor spaces so that they have insisted
all uh all along but
it's still the the um
the basic measures are are the same that
i have mentioned before now regarding
the long-term
impact in terms of health i
believe we haven't seen the full picture
yet
so what is done in various
clinical settings is to set up cohorts
and study uh groups of people that had
covet to monitor what
a kind of sequelae meaning
consequence can be can can be observed
because i don't think we have seen the
full picture yet
um and regarding the contact racing i
think it always goes both ways
um i mean the the the forward looking is
sort of
[Music]
to be uh prevented by putting contacts
especially high-risk contacts in
quarantine and
so the backward contact tracing is
always done
in order to find other people that might
have been exposed to
thank you thank you very much i will now
give the four to oliver grim
hello hi do you hear me yes we do
can you hear me yes we do okay super
fantastic just very very high oliver
again with the austrian newspaper
very briefly first of all questions to
all
uh both of the um both the commissioner
and dr amon why is there still no
european-wide
tracing app in your personal assessment
secondly why are there no european-wide
testing capacities at all the big major
airports
also in your personal experience and
thirdly why do not all member states
provide you with all the necessary data
about the the spread
of the disease i'm referring for example
to the very good graph in your
document i think on page four or five
that shows you the age curve
and you can see that i think only half
of member states have actually provided
these data which i think quite quite
quite easily
uh collected thank you a touch
i'll touch a little bit on the mobile
apps and the tracing apps
we all know that contact tracing plays a
very important role
in phases of of the crisis management
and in breaking the lines of
transmission of this virus
and men most member states have decided
to launch
mobile apps and a number of them have
already done so not all
and in order to facilitated cross-border
exchange of the information
the commission will be hosting an
interoperability gateway at the end of
this
[Music]
month at the beginning of next month in
order to help so so we are
aware of this um and
i'll let andre answer the issue to do
with that with testing
um saying that um
i'll let andrea take that up and then
we'll come back
director aman please go ahead yes thank
you
regarding the apps um uh the
uh as the commissioner said many
countries have put
ups in place we are now in a process of
uh
uh getting the information from these
countries how these apps worked
and there are different issues in terms
in particular in terms of
the percentage of the population that is
actually downloading it
which has different different reasons
so um we would like to put all these uh
experiences together to see um what we
can learn from it because you also have
to consider
this is the first time that this
technology has been used
uh so widely and you can't expect that
it
works a hundred percent uh perfect
so we have but we have to now take the
experience and develop it further
regarding the airports i think this is
again it's
measures that countries have to put in
place
and reporting of the countries we are
constantly really in contact with
our colleagues that do the reporting
to see where their where their obstacles
are
to uh forward the information to us
um thank you very much um i will take
the last question a journalist i
i hear you i see that there is a general
interest in
having raising questions about spain so
natalia i think you wanted to raise that
question with the support of your
colleague journalists go ahead
hello do you hear me we hear you yes we
hear you
okay good uh yes things that we finally
can ask
on spain which is the country that is
most affected by
these new outbreaks um so basically i
wanted to know
if the commission and the ecdc has
any specific recommendations for spain i
mean like
you made a full range of options uh
for countries like to try to stop the
outbreaks and
in spain uh more or less they are doing
what you are saying but uh still there
are a lot of cases
and still biking so what is your
specific recommendation
to spain and if you are worried about
the situation there
does andre you want to take that not
close yes
andrea please go ahead sorry yes thank
you
i mean um i we are normally not com
commenting on on what countries do
so my my recommendation is
in the same way we are in contact with
spanish colleagues
and see also where we can support them
in principle they they are following up
on these uh
um still localized outbreaks that
they're seeing
and um uh implementing the measures
uh it what we're seeing in many
countries
is that and that's not only in spain
that a lot of the transmission that's
ongoing right now
is um due to private meetings
uh festivities uh big family dinners
weddings uh you know all the all the um
conventions that you have in uh with
your with your friends and
and and family and that is um what the
in
in many countries is actually driving
the
the epidemiological picture so
we are in contact with the countries to
see how we can support them
thank you very much i said it was the
last question but i'm going i lied sorry
there's still really the one very very
very last
for uh cyrantes scientists go ahead
do you hear us
can you hear me yes no you can't hear me
it's a it's a very
it's a very quick question for
commissioner gary this in greece we see
videos of some politicians kissing kinds
of priests
or not wearing masks do you believe this
is a consistent political message
have you spoken to national politicians
across europe
to send consistent messages especially
when it comes to this matter
thanks i speak with the ministers of
health across europe
on an extremely frequent basis from day
one of this
pandemic which i was in january february
we're in very close contact and
i think the messages of what we need to
be doing in a pandemic
and the measures we as citizens need to
be taken are not
um specific to work to which uh
to uh what a job we do or where we are
i think that these are measures that
that go across the board
um so uh we are in very close contact
with all the ministers
at the political level the messages are
very clear
i just wanted to be in ending
i just wanted to highlight one or two
points which i feel are important and i
want to thank you for your
for your presence and your interest
today um
and really thank also um the agency for
the
very strong information coming out but i
wanted to highlight something my
responsibility
as a commissioner for health and food
safety
is to remain vigilant and this is what
we have been doing throughout
the last uh eight or nine months
and although i understand that some of
you may consider the fact that our
messages today may have been a little
bit
pessimistic i would call them our
messages are being proactive
our responsibility is to send to
coordinate and collaborate
with men with member states and this is
what we're doing
and to send clear messages to member
states as well
and i would urge to to ask
member states to consider what we have
put into place
after working with them from the
beginning for joint procurements for
ventilators for joint procurements for
laboratory equipment
for personal protective equipment for
therapeutics
these are there available the commission
has come forward with these and these
now need to be considered
in the way to go forward what we want to
avoid
and this is why we are standing before
you today is to
a repeat of what we had last spring and
avoid generalized lockdowns
and i we're standing here today to raise
these
in a sense alarm bells uh in a proactive
way
and um i think that we can do this and
we can move forward with this way and be
and be
uh very effective um
this is a time when we need to each to
show
a collective and personal responsibility
and we as a commission are doing
everything possible to ensure
that the member states are supported in
a very difficult
time for for for themselves and for each
and every citizen
um not only in europe but globally thank
you
thank you very much commissioner thank
you very much director thank you very
much to you colleagues um
i understand there's lots of questions
this is a topic that clearly is of
interest to you
name is suggested to have more regular
briefings from the cdc we'll definitely
see
how we can organize things to make sure
that we have a good information flow
and that we can deal with your questions
but for now
i have to stop the current press
conference we will switch to the press
midday briefing so again thank you very
much
stay healthy and see you at the midday
briefing bye
[Music]
you